bonsoir philippe gilbert vous êtes
informaticiens vous vivez à lussac
saint-émilion en gironde mais depuis de
nombreuses années vous passer plusieurs
semaines par an au sri lanka où vous
étiez le jour du tsunami
vous raconter cette aventure dans un
livre qui s'appelle les larmes de ceylan
aux éditions des équateurs alors le 26
décembre 2004 vous êtes donc dans le sud
de l'île de ceylan dans un bungalow vous
ai fait construire dans un village de
pêcheurs près de temps gaulle vous y
vivez quatre mois par an d'état moureu
de ses langues de tomber amoureux de
ceylan vous avez des amis sri lankais
notamment m/h parce qu'il préfère qu'on
appelle comme ça et kamina sa femme ils
ont une petite fille aux syndicats 7 ans
qui joue avec votre petite fille
juliette qui a quatre ans voilà en effet
delphine votre fille et jérôme votre
gendre sont venus passer des vacances à
un scellant qu'il ce matin là votre
gendre vous propose d'aller pêcher mais
avant il va faire le marché attend
gaulle avec votre fille les 9 heures
vous surveillez les deux fillettes elles
dessinent
et là une touriste qui loue une chambre
chez un mach votre voisin sri lankais
est surprise par une vague que vous
qualifiez de téméraires dans votre livre
et se réfugie dans le jardin et vous
l'aidez à ce moment là vous avez le
sentiment qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ou vous trouvé ça
presque naturel non à ce moment là je
trouve cela tout à fait naturel je suis
habitué à voir la vague de temps en
temps on y en ait chez le bord du bus à
l'eau donc non je suis pas du tout
surpris pas surpris alors l'eau passe la
clôture du petit jardinet vous réagissez
pas plus à ce moment-là vous rentrez
dans votre bungalow pour pas être
mouillé et là le le flot d'eau
s'engouffre
dans la pièce en fréquence en tout sur
son passage dire que la la la porte
d'entrée vole en éclats quoi là vous
comprenez qu'il se passe quelque chose
de wil à ce moment là je prends
conscience même si j'ai pas conscience
totale de ce qui va réellement se passer
quelques secondes après là je commence à
comprendre que ce n'est pas normal vous
comprenez qu'il se passe quelque chose
il ya un deuxième floqué torrentielles
dit vous vous avait de l'eau jusqu'au
cou et vous sortez du du bungalow où
vous êtes réfugiés et dehors la vision
est absolument terrifiante ya une vague
monstrueuse et vous avez cette image
vite j'ai l'impression d'être comme un
égyptien dans le film les 10
commandements au moment où la mer rouge
se referme quoi si vous êtes submergé
par la masse d'eau c'est ça c'est ça et
ma première pensée ça a été
dur pas souffrir ouais ouais quand vous
voyez un truc comme ça
là vous pensez que vous allez mourir à
ce moment-là arriver j'en suis tout à
fait persuadé je suis simplement rassuré
à l'idée que ça va ça va ça va aller
très vite que je souffrais pas
pour moi je suis mort
heureusement voilà vous êtes transporté
à 30 mètres de chez vous heureusement
vous accrocher un cocotier et là vous
prenez comme ça quoi comme une espèce de
deux bouées de sauvetage c'est le cas de
le dire et vous laisser passer la vague
et vous parvenez à continuer à respirer
donc à survivre
tout ça se passe très vite en vraiment
très très vite et après une fois que
vous êtes accroché
c'est interminable
faut que ça cesse faut que ça cesse
et puis ça cesse voilà et aux enfants
étaient en sécurité la chance de ma
fille et de mon gens c'est qu'ils
étaient partis au marché ce jour là à
une heure tout à fait inhabituelle
d'habitude ils partent au marché
beaucoup plus tard que cela ils sont
partis et d'habitude ils emmènent
juliette avec eux et là je le redis vu
leur laisser juliette elle est avec 70
tranquille laisser je vais les garder
vous demandez donc le sens aux 110 la
fidh de vos amis sri lankais et juliette
oui il faut savoir que la vue le
spectacle auquel j'ai assisté je n'ai
pas le moindre doute sur le fait que
juliette et aux 110 soit soit morte
ne peuvent pas avoir je vois la chambre
où elle était je vois il ya un bateau
dedans il ya à face et donc je n'ai plus
de doute là dessus maintenant il me
reste un truc terrible affaire c'est
d'annoncer ça m'a fait il de revenir si
vous voulez
d'aller vers eux et d'affronter le
regard de ma fille qui va me voir
arriver moi vivant tout seul sans sa
fille
l'a effectivement voulais retrouver sur
le marché de temps gaulle ils sont même
pas mouillé évidemment puisque c'est à
des kilomètres de là vous dit jamais je
n'oublierai le cri de delphine cuit
dément insoutenable
oui
rien d'autre à rajouter
ça m'a marqué pour le restant de mes
jours
alors ensuite vous allez dans un hôtel
qui est situé à 7 km de tango rôle sur
les hauteurs un hôtel qui s'appelle eva
lanka et là vous êtes choqués parce
qu'en fait les touristes évidemment ils
savent pas ce qui s'est passé donc ils
profitent de la journée de vacances
comme si de rien n'était et nous on
arrive là on fait encore que ma fille et
mon gendre était correctement habillés
mais en ce qui me concerne j'étais en
loques en sang
ça fait un drôle d'effet de ne voir
qu'il ya des gens qui ont pu ne pas se
rendre compte du tout de ce qui s'était
passé il ya une personne qui concerne
est quand même celle n devynck de lci
qu'il a avec son compagnon emmanuel
carrère l'écrivain oui et elle vous
parlez vous témoigner sur lci de ce qui
s'est passé en fait ce jour là oui et ça
ça a été le départ de tout ça a été
si vous utilisez des mots comme ça dans
notre situation c'est une chance inouïe
une chance inouïe parce que si vous
voulez il est évident qu'on aurait de
toute façon aider les très proches amis
de ne serait-ce que de cette sortie de
ça mais là le fait que j'ai été par
chance le premier à témoigner
ça a tout de suite amené les médias vers
nous quand on est rentré en france
bon c'est pas trop trop mon style de
jouer avec ça mais là je crois que
j'avais pas le choix mais il a fallu que
je sois très con pour ne pas jouer à ce
jeu donc on a laissé les articles
paraître dans paris match
on a même été jusqu'à accepter qu'une
photo de juliette 70 soit diffusé
c'était pas de gaieté de coeur mais je
crois que c'était le seul moyen pour
qu'on récolte la somme maximale nous
permettant d'aider non plus une deux
trois familles mais quelque 50 ou 100
familles puisque c'était notre objectif
en parallèle à ce moment là alors ce que
vous découvrez à ce moment là c'est
qu'il est impossible de rapatrier le
corps de votre petite fille juliette
pour la faire incinérer en france cesser
purement interdite oui il faut le faire
au sri lanka et un jour vous irez jeter
les cendres de juliette dans un jardin
botanique à kandy près d'un massif de
bougainvilliers alors vous vivez depuis
avec une espèce de culpabilité
vous dites évidemment j'aurais pu la
sauver alors il ya une chose qu'on prend
pas bien dans le livre quand la vague
arriver ce qu'elle est sur la terrasse
de votre bungalow sur la terrasse du
bengale
mhl et une escale dans une pièce de la
maison de votre voisin une dizaine de
mètres derrière moi même pas en fin
d'hiver admettons une dizaine de mètres
derrière moi dans une dans une chambre
une chambre d'hôte quoi si vous voyez à
le jouer avec sa petite copine le samedi
il ya dit m maliki m vous l'aviez sous
les yeux à ce moment là j'avais aucune
raison à ce moment là j'ai eu avant que
la vague arrive de les surveiller de
très près c'est un endroit très très
très en sécurité c'est vraiment ça sa
véritable paradis donc aucune raison de
les surveiller c'est vrai que d'habitude
par contre après entre le moment où la
vague m'est arrivé dessus le moment je
me suis retrouvé trente mètres plus loin
avec le accroché comme un conte as
cocotiers je peux même pas dire que j'ai
pensé à ce moment là au centre et la
julienne je peux le temps j'ai pas vu
j'ai pensé à vous strictement rien voilà
alors là vous commencez avec votre
gendre jérôme 1,1 à échafauder une
association pour aider les habitants de
ce petit village de pêcheurs vous
inventer ce qu'on appelle le kit de
nécessité alors c'est quoi exactement
savez ça consiste en d'abord on
s'improvise un conte n'a jamais fait
maneater donc vous arrivez avec un trac
pas possible en vous demandant si
vous allez être à la hauteur parce que
c'est quand même
mais pas le droit de se planter
et puis vous allez à l'essentiel vous
distribuez des feuilles de papier dans
le village et vous dites aux gens en
fait vous vous prenez le tv tu as besoin
de quoi oui la commande quoi tu as
besoin de quoi on n'est pas les blancs
sauveur venant à la rescousse de ce nom
là on
on se fait tout petit de quoi tu as
besoin et on s'aperçoit ça va très vite
c'est en quelques jours les besoins sont
toujours les mêmes un lit un matelas et
ça ça a pris une importance terrible
après vous verrez un moustiquaire des
ustensiles de cuisine
à la vouli tilly a des besoins
enfin c'est vraiment élémentaire
leur rendre leur dignité en fait voilà
attention la plupart des familles non
non non plus de toi non plus deux mais
au delà du fait qu'elle n'ait plus de
toit et plus de maison elle mange dans
des feuilles de journaux et les enfants
dorment par terre sur les ruines des
maisons et ça je l' ai vu de mes yeux vu
là vous vous dites ya urgence alors vous
cherchez pas à vous organiser alors ça
vous partez au quart de tour vous foncez
alors vous fait des bêtises vous n'etes
et quatre jours à équiper 10 familles
parce que vous pensez qu'il faut faire
le tour des commerçants etc etc et après
on devient un petit peu moins bête on se
dit bon on va s'organiser on va
distribuer les tickets aux gens ils vont
aller eux-mêmes dans les boutiques tout
ça se met en or bon il faut reconnaître
aussi qu'on a là affaire à un peuple qui
n'a pas du tout la mentalité des peuples
occidentaux on est sur des gens qui sont
face à ce malheur d'une dignité déjà
absolue
extrêmement réservé pas du il n'y a pas
de panique une scène de panique alors
que faut pas oublier que là on est au
bout du au bout de la première semaine
on sait qu'on va avoir 700 familles à
l'équipe et on a coupé là ça y est on le
sait on va voir on va on a mis une
frontière si vous voulez medac et tire
mais c'est horrible déjà ça cette
frontière viens de dire bats toi tu
étais petit l'autre côté de la route tu
rentres pas dans le monde ccc
voilà vous vous mettez au boulot avec
jérôme pour essayer de les aider est en
revanche pas de trace de ong vous dit où
sont les dons où sont les 20 tonnes de
médicaments a mené dans sept airbus 310
ça a coûté trois cent mille euros pour
la pour acheminer les dons vous voyez
rien voyez des 4,4 flamboyant dites vous
des 4 4 9 de la croix-rouge et vous
dites qu'une de ses voitures vous
permettrait avoue enfin tous les cas aux
gens du sri lanka de reconstruire sans
maison
dans l'avion on se on s'inquiétait de
savoir comment on allait pouvoir nous
tous petits là on a les gangs et de
guérilla s'entendre avec toutes ces ong
sur place ouais parce que comme vous on
a entendu que il y avait
des dons faramineux que toutes les ong
étaient là bas que se dit comment on va
trouver une autre place la has a pas été
difficile on était les seuls ouais on
était tout seul quand je suis arrivé au
début février on était tout seul quand
juste quand mon gendre est parti fin
avril absolument personne non c'est
incroyable parce que la france a envoyé
190 millions d'euros
alors il paraît que l'argent est placé
dans les sicav monétaires que ça c'est
un véritable scandale bien d'accord
quand je lis moi dans le parisien c'est
le monsieur météo lui même qui le dit
que hilali patron de la croix rouge
après avoir été patron de la canicule
voilà qu'il a 100 millions de dons et à
aujourd'hui ils ont dépensé 7 1 il ya
quand même quelque chose d'absolument
obscènes à détourner de cette façon
l'argent que les gens ont donné pour le
sri lanka la thaïlande le laos est
absolument scandaleuse oui il ya 7 % des
sommes qui ont été données au sri
lankais le reste ils n'ont pas vu voilà
moi je ne je ne remets pas en cause le
la bonne foi de ces gens je dis c'est de
la bêtise mais en même temps c'est tout
à fait scandaleux donc il faut demander
des comptes à la croix rouge du sur et
ben on va appeler le docteur robert
sebag
[Musique]
il
bonsoir
alors cet administrateur national la
croix-rouge votre fonction en fait c'est
de faire la somme des dons reçus de
savoir comment l'argent est dépensé les
missions sur le terrain c'est moins
votre truc qu'on fasse qu'un vous qui
gérez le pognon j'en ai fait une voie là
alors où est l'argent ou et le pognon
alors ce que ce que je peux vous assuré
il ya une partie de l'argent qui a été
dépensé et il ya une programmation on a
signé sans en ce qui vous concerne en
désaccord il ya soixante dix ans déjà
non mais vous dit combien cette sur 107
sur son visage alors oui la boue sur les
93 millions il ya 70 millions d'euros
qui sont engagés aujourd'hui il ya mille
maisons deux hôpitaux au sri lanka en
indonésie à l'approvisionnement en eau
qui se fait dans la région d'ankara dans
la région dans la région de galles vous
le savez il faut des bureaux il faut une
logistique en indonésie on a pu plus de
50 personnes qui sont sur place il ya eu
le tremblement de terre sur l'île niasse
on a été tout de suite là on a remis 10
litres d'eau par personne et par jour
160 mille litres d'eau à filtrer il
fallait transporter le matériel alors
l'argent il n'est pas dépensée en
immédiat il est pas dépenser comme sale
argent et pourquoi mais
pourquoi vous avez les autres il vous
faut des récipiendaires il faut des gens
de confiance vous pouvez pas distribuer
l'argent à n'importe qui vous connaissez
ce pays comme on attendait comme
beaucoup
que philippe gilbert mais non mais
pourquoi est ce que les braves pêcheurs
qui ont eu tout détruit on leur dit pas
à chacun on vous donne je sais pas moi
dix mille dollars
pour acheter un bateau on est en train
ce qu'on n'a jamais fait si vous voulez
d'avoir des partenaires locaux
d'associations là on vérifie qu'elle
soit entre mais
s'est enroulé autour des choses comme ça
que vous et donc c'est bien parce que
votre discours au moins il est honnête
vous vous êtes en train de faire un
constat d'échec c'est incroyable c'est
un jeu rodez je vais retourner au mois
de juillet au sri lanka à côté de
medhatiyah il arrange rien donné mais
qui voudra venir manger d'en définir le
jour où andré lorsque viendront 70
millions
excusez moi docteur
attendez attendez il est en question il
n'est pas question de mettre ici en
doute l'efficacité est là et la probité
de la croix rouge c'est pas du tout
notre propos efficacité un peu comme
tous les cas d'un coup rouge a fait ses
preuves depuis depuis plus d'un siècle
mois pour dire
ce que je veux dire simplement voilà ce
que je me disais docteur ce que dit
philippe gilbert il dit voilà il dit moi
je vais retourner parce que c'est un
amoureux de s'élancer plus qu'un
touriste c'est un mec a construit une
baraque la basse gilbert bon donc il va
aller là bas il va voir ces gens qui
vont continuer à bouffer dans des
comédies dans des journaux à dormir sur
des lits alors que vous vous avez fait
pas des millions et des millions d'euros
sur des placées en sicav nés de mères
c'est ça qui concerne un sujet pareil
vraiment je veux pas polémiquer surtout
pas avec vous ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on a repéré un certain nombre
d'associations locales vous même je vous
le dis je le dis je lis dans tout le
monde je veux dire nous sommes tout à
fait prêts sur votre association parce
que vous êtes quelqu'un de confiance de
votre village vous avez vécu vous avez
construit à financer un projet je le dis
c'est pas c'est pas le chemin que j'ai
dit j'ai pris devant vous avez raison il
faut de l'argent jeu important mais vous
c'est très très long vous être submergé
excusez moi je ne vaux par la
bureaucratie quoi mais la bureaucratie
locale aussi la bureaucratie locale
faire des virements d'argent locaux à
voir les dédouanements vous savez que
même sur des médicaments d d d d d
ddd filtreurs d'eau on doit à la douane
on doit payer un certain nombre de taxes
tout est contrôlé vous pouvez pas rués
pour une énorme face à une catastrophe
comme si vous envoyez des aiguilles par
la nôtre des petites équipes de rien du
jeune fille vous savez que je disais ma
religion quand vous allez arriver à
l'aéroport vous allez vous n'allez pas
dire que vous êtes une ong vous allez
dire vous êtes touristes ça nous
permettait de rentrer tranquillement
dans le pays si jamais vous disiez ong
il vous bloquer et vous restiez quinze
jours à colombo je vienne où on passait
comme touristes on a ouvert un compte en
banque tout de suite là bas on fait on
faisait virer l'argent la barre les
faits on hamm est montée des équipes
avec des strings payer mais je sais j'en
limites avec tout l'argent mis à jouer
et même des gens
mais ils roupies par jour à chaque c'est
dans quelques branches malgache est
décevant je me dis à bientôt nous nous
on a fait je la retiens si les gens
quand deux ne jurent ses journaux et
vite rapidement et quand on touche là
secours eu à débourser d'ici là on
entend quand on joue au village s'est
enfoncée
on se demande toujours où va le pognon
voit la croix rouge tout un contenu
justement j'en ai je vous il faut aussi
jugé les programmes qu'ils ont faits qui
ont lieu aujourd'hui au sri lanka vous
n'êtes pas tomber sur les villages mais
je le dis et je le répète notre
association mais non écoutez vous
connaissez comme moi le sri lanka la
cote était non je dis vous faut pas
remettre en question on va construire
1000 maisons on va construire trois
centres hospitaliers
il ya 25 personnes dont 1000 maisons
avec mais il ya urgence
on est aussi en indonésie on est aussi
un pays où gallup personnes en somalie
parce que la somalie a été touché on n'a
pas parlé on parle pas mais ce même nom
mais cette urgence de lits des matelas
ces deux moustiquaires
aujourd'hui pour résumer la situation
rend 6 où tu vas sa conversion au psg en
même temps pourquoi pas avec l'argent
plus un tour clair vous ne payez pas des
gens tout le monde serait d'accord pour
payer d engager des gens payés la
filière mise en chômage en france plr
héritier
effectivement dans le poujadisme et donc
malheureusement pas eu tous et pendant
ce temps là ce sont les banques qui sont
du pognon avec l'argent qui est dessus
mais sur les comptes
rapporte du pognon font pas du tout mais
pas vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas
déverser vous pouvez pas déverser sur un
pays 25 millions d'euros comme ça tout
d'un coup donc tout l'argent je peux
vous assurer c'est de
l'argent l'argent l'argent qui est
l'argent qui n'est pas dépensé tous les
intérêts sont reversés au programme asie
vous savez très bien que les période de
reconstruction ça va durer longtemps
encore à les remettre en cause le but au
bout de chou non ce que après le
tremblement de terre en iran il ya
aujourd'hui encore des
neiges des seules organisations étaient
prenait croix rouge française on n'a pas
eu beau en est beaucoup moins d'argent
que le tsunami avec présence urbam
aujourd'hui à monter un certain nombre
de programmes je vous dis on vous
connaît ans et un rouge mais gens
méchants enchaînement minable non mais
mais mais là je peux pas non plus il ya
des volontaires c'est pas un problème
d'organisation des morts mais on peut
pas faire n'importe quoi on a aussi des
comptes à rendre parle pas les genres
s'est retiré mais bien je suis d'accord
mais quand vous avez des partenaires
comme monsieur on est tout à fait prêt
je le redis à aider spécifiquement son
village mais c'est pas le sien non c'est
non mais oui
et puis avoir des enfants c'est pas
nouveau mais la part où j'avais une
vision d'ensemble plus et bien sûr si
l'écran pour que quelqu'un vous êtes ça
c'est bien gentil de dire ça la
maintenance en menaçant mais c'est pas
ça c'est une règle vaut mourir soit
deux villages des pensionnés vous pour
avoir des témoins deux villages se
prêtait
des défauts aider tout le monde on
pourrait on pourrait avoir ici en face
des villageois dans lesquels nous sommes
présents on a fait des milliers d'imagés
sperme et quelques immigrés du congrès
geste merci à la croix-rouge bonne
blague merci heureusement que jamais
l'organisation bien je vois déjà ces
derniers qu'est ce que je fais ce que
vous parce que c'est ça qui est
important vous vous habiter là-bas vous
y allez plusieurs mois par an vous êtes
encore une fois vraiment sri lankais
d'esprit pour plus qu est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut faire qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je pense qu'il faut faire
moi je crois que je viens de m'exprimer
suffisamment sur le sujet jeu est tout
simplement il faut que l'argent qui
aujourd'hui d'or dans des banques soient
utilisées d'une façon ou d'une autre
alors c'est comme le dit fort justement
laurent ruquier s'est par exemple payer
chômeurs en france et tant pis si on
fait du poujadisme parce que là s'il ya
dix ou quinze ans plus bon ou tout
simplement le le distribuer il y en a
pas besoin d'autant que vous en avez des
petites associations comme nous qui vont
au moins essayer de faire l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire de ramener très vite ces
villages a dit parce que quand vous
dites mon village niveau de vie la jeune
je peux vous assurer que j'ai fait la
route de colombo à je sais où vous étiez
vous étiez plutôt sur la côte est
d'accord bien des figues alors voilà
voilà mais toute la côte qui est là je
peux vous dire que les gens n'ont pas
été aidé du tout sert toute la côte
entre colombo et thorgal et au monde
total n'a pas été aidé du tout gaulle
par exemple ça a été non c'est qu' à ce
qui a été fait non c'est dans ces villes
c'est la plupart du temps on a travaillé
sur le plan hôpitaux
voilà là il ya eu beaucoup de choses de
faites donc ça je remets pas ça en
question mais c'est pas parce qu'on
construit un hôpital qu'il faut laisser
les gens
dans la merde aux bords de l'eure au
bord de l'eau vous voyez bon voila et et
surtout ce qui me choque c'est que c'est
des sommes faramineuses dont on entend
parler alors que nous avec cent mille
euros c'est une goutte d'eau on a
redonné à 700 familles la dignité
élémentaire dont ils avaient besoin
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux